[Music]
detection the nation and voluntarist
entry please use the there's such a high
level of fear here people don't know
what could happen in Amman you are home
thank you this is the beginning of Islam
taking over Canada and I'm not the only
one that feels that way any new
decisions they decide to deposit me
Crusaders at that time I will be killed
in the United States when you talk about
illegal border crossers it's typically
about people coming into the u.s. from
Mexico but these are not typical times
we're about four miles south the
Canadian border in Buffalo New York
this building here may look like a
nondescript schoolhouse but inside are
people from dozens of countries hoping
for legal asylum in Canada this man from
Bangladesh drove up from New York City
nearly seven hours away to beg the staff
at VA for help so do you want to stay in
the United States or do you want to try
to go back to Canada yeah the
desperation has definitely increased I
never in my life thought that my country
would be the one people were running
from never in January President Trump
signed an executive order restricting
immigration from seven muslim-majority
countries for 90 days halting refugee
admission and banning all Syrian
refugees indefinitely the order stranded
people around the world and was widely
condemned while federal judges blocked
the initial ban and part of a subsequent
one Trump's immigration crackdown has
sparked a climate of fear in contrast
Kenda's prime minister Justin Trudeau is
welcoming immigrants often through
social media asylum seekers are now
leaving the u.s. for Canada by the
thousands but with this influx and
global concerns over terrorism not
everyone is thrilled like this mayor of
a Canadian border town when you're
starting to get a number of people
coming from different countries that's
what's concerning our residents with the
bigger numbers coming we're gonna see
more criminals or more undesirable vivir
mainly helps asylum seekers with
immediate family members in Canada
though they also support a small number
of people who want to stay in the u.s.
what do we have right here um so this is
the list of everyone who's going to the
border tomorrow once people realize
everyone rushing then I see it how many
those had names
11:11 I just looking at the countries
three Nigerians seven people from Yemen
and a Haitian
there it is yeah wow this is all the
names that I'm sent that I'm waiting for
an appointment yeah god this looks like
a couple hundred oh yeah yeah it's about
two hundred fifty Wow yeah that's just
us I mean that we're just one
organization it's not possible to claim
asylum in both countries after 9/11 the
US and Canada signed the safe
third-country agreement
it states that refugees must seek
protection in the first of the two
countries they entered asylum seekers
from around the world including some
from VV are flocking to this small town
in upstate New York it's become one of
the busiest crossing points for people
fleeing Trump's America if they can
manage to cross the border the safe
third country agreement no longer
applies most arrived here after taking
buses from New York City to a nearby
town and then catching a cab to the
border we're currently sitting on a
dead-end street in Champlain New York
it's a relatively desolate area Canada
is about 15 feet away and there's
actually Canadian police stationed a
little past the border a conservative
Canadian news outlet is the first time
we get that not everyone in Canada is a
welcoming asylum seekers
yeah so you need to the Canadian border
getting arrested is actually a good
thing here because it opens up a path to
claiming asylum this reporter described
a very different scene from the one we
saw he looked nothing like what you'd
expect a refugee to look like cuz he
arrived in a cab he certainly didn't
have any guns to his head it didn't look
like he was being persecuted in any way
on his way over here
[Music]
and this you will be arrested if you
cross here report to the border child
despite Canada's reputation for
tolerance a recent Reuters poll shows
nearly half of Canadians want to see
illegal border crossers deported no
matter the circumstances and some ultra
nationalist groups have been taking
matters into their own hands and
patrolling this border there's been a
recent rise in hate crimes within Canada
some caught on camera know you well
they're gonna work here it is the law to
know English
you're from Paki I went to Montreal an
hour from the border to get a better
sense of what's driving this some people
have asked me this question do I
consider myself a racist I would say
more than you like your culture and if
you like your culture is that called
racism George halak is a Lebanese
Canadian and Christian founder of the
Canadian Coalition of concerned citizens
he started the group earlier this year
and calls it a movement to protect
Canada many other members of the group
wanted to talk in the days before I
arrived but only George showed up for
the interview his peer said they were
afraid I'd make them look like races but
here's what some say online right now
the government is giving a lot of money
for Refugees they're giving a lot of
money for people to come here and
they're not really vetting them like 100
percent I feel that they're coming here
for a specific the specific goal to take
over the country and to make it into
Islamic country within a period of 50
years that's quite a task they have
Muslims make up about 3% of the Canadian
population and they're increasingly
becoming the target of far-right groups
all right we have some breaking news
from Quebec City on January 29th
Alexandre de Bie sunette a 27 year old
college student killed six people at a
mosque in Quebec City Trump used the
shooting to support his call for a
travel ban it's a terrible reminder of
why we must remain vigilant and why the
president is taking steps to be
proactive rather than reactive when it
comes to our nation's safety and
security yet ironically the shooter in
this case was white and had grown up in
Canada I'm not sure harder percent what
happened with that mosque I'll make my
decision after the Charles made until
then I assumed that it was nothing
related with racism it was just someone
that was crazy I agree that was probably
crazy but he attacked a religious house
of worship okay and he like made a lot
of statements that he was targeting
Georg organizes rallies across the
country to protest what he calls
Trudeau's open border policies he
coordinates with other far-right groups
like soldiers of Odin who do street
patrols of Muslim neighborhoods and la
moot known for their wolf-like house a
[Applause]
lot of people see them as nationalistic
to the point where maybe they're against
people from other countries in a way
that could be taken as very aggressive
well it's people I would call them
picture art Canadians that love
immigrants that love all types of people
in this world they want to make sure
that Canada stays safe as a nation
several thousand people have illegally
crossed into Canada since January
refugee advocates say the safe third
country agreement is encouraging people
to risk their lives to get into the
country these men from Ghana recently
lost most of their fingers in sub-zero
weather
this is your new home right here yeah
this my home yes this my new home
Mamadou fled the Ivory Coast during the
civil war that killed his father and
fears that if he is sent back he too
will be killed he spent years in New
York City and now shares a room with 16
men at this YMCA turned refugee shelter
in Montreal some 10 years in the country
you're paying taxes you have a job you
can apartment and then all of a sudden
in one night immigration comes looking
for you
yes and everything changes every teacher
changes well I want you t to power less
than one week
they keep looking for me when they're
coming for the second time and the third
time I don't know I'm not longer safe
immigration arrests have risen nearly
40% since Trump took office
Mamadou says he was so frightened that
he left New York with only the clothes
on his back and no phone or map after
being turned away at an official border
crossing he started walking through a
forest to avoid being detected
he waited through a river and then
another and climbed a small mountain he
could no longer feel his fingers or toes
he knew he was in Canada when he saw a
stop sign in French he then passed out
and was later found by a police officer
he had walked for more than nine hours
my man is I don't want to sit want to I
can receive I don't know the consequence
just Dini you got to save my life
and I know you cost me a lot I went with
Mamadou as he prepares to meet the
police officer who rescued him it was
nearby the fans and he was standing
rigid not moving and he was not talking
was just was it wasn't able to talk tell
me I don't even know because already
conscious it's a feel good press
conference for the RCMP but it's clear
they don't intend to answer any
political questions so this is a problem
when is awful
I'm not here to to judge or to analyze
what's going on at the border right now
I'm there because I'm a police officer
I'm doing my job after the press
conference I asked an RCMP officer how
the agency is responding to the influx
we're seeing a definite increase in 2016
a sharp increase like I mentioned
earlier it's it's been there for years
it's not a new phenomenon
but the increase yeah the amount of
people coming and then no when we never
seen it you might come to a point where
we're gonna be beyond logistics though
the officer wouldn't comment about
anything controversial and how do you
guys feel about the situation to the
south of the border now what's going on
in the US do you feel like this is
exacerbating it this is causing more
people to come to Canada I don't want to
go down either off-camera officers were
more candid saying something needs to be
done to slow the tide of people coming
over the border so far Trudeau has been
largely quiet about the refugee crisis
his office turned down my request for an
interview but calls for Canada to pull
out of the agreement with the US have
been escalating since the recent death
of a border crosser a woman who is
believed to be a citizen of Ghana was
found in a field about half a mile from
the Canadian border near the tiny town
of noise Minnesota the body of Mavis OTA
a 57 year old from Ghana was discovered
in a farmer's field she'd been living in
the US and it was believed she was
trying to join her daughter in Canada hi
Zane is a Syrian activist and graduate
student who crossed the legally into
Quebec from New York just one week
before I met her what do you think of
Montreal so far I join her as she heads
to the home of a woman who runs a
domestic violence shelter here she
started taking in asylum seekers from
some of the countries subject that
Trump's travel ban
you lived through the siege of east 11
and what was that like what was no
day-to-day there were a lot of bombing a
lot of people we love them my friend
Zane says she was jailed for over a year
for working as a nurse in a rebel Health
Hospital and participating in protests
against the Assad regime
you spent 14 months in jail you lived
through this horrible siege you finally
escaped and you came to the United
States but you didn't want to stay in
the United States the MFI making it
evident mr. Howe make it a mess in there
man oh be a beautiful tight soccer dad
hey buddy hi rosani mom cannot roshaniya
divinity rajanya us to do underneath
Lincoln and no and our job I suppose
oh she decided to head north after
seeing how Trudeau was greeting refugees
now you are home thank you
just think if you use welcome I thought
in youth everyday and they welcome that
if you do the same status here remains
uncertain like mama do she initially
tried to enter the country an illegal
crossing but when denied she walked
across the border that drastically
reduces her chances of getting asylum
and now she just hopes that Trudeau will
follow through on his promises they have
responsibility with what they are think
who had any with them Madonna and Norton
love of my live a little
ermine and I've ever done is no photo
for her mama trust me the happiness not
roster Berman Robert Oh mechana-parrot
long hot October with the telogen
candidate are four beyond the study hey
this is danny go with AJ plus you can
check out the rest of our divided
America series when we examine the tech
elite embracing the proper movement
refugees fleeing the US for Canada the
battle over land rights in America and
the attempt to defund Planned Parenthood
right now on the aj+ YouTube channel
thanks for watching